all right now as promised what i'm going
to do is i'm going to send you in to
breakouts to have a look at uh part
three and part four together um it's 2
34 so i'm going to give you
let's call that like seven or eight
minutes okay i'll give you a timer and
i'll wander around the rooms and see how
you're faring
what i'd like you to do is part three
you can see is the big muscly question
it's worth three marks um if you've
already gotten up to that like maybe
you've been working away plugging away
in the background or you attempted this
you know during your revision
i'm looking for i've got two fairly
distinct ways of solving this and i want
you to see if you can find
more than that if you can and and
importantly make a decision about why
one method is better than another if you
think that is the case okay
so go ahead and do that if you have time
to get onto part four then do it um give
me a second i'm gonna arrange the
breakout rooms now and then i'm gonna
send you off okay i think we're all back
so welcome uh back to the main room uh
as promised i'm gonna show you a couple
of ways to do this and it was really
interesting to me as i wandered around
the rooms that like this is a question
which in some ways once you see the
solution it's a bit like as i've
described before seeing a finished
jigsaw puzzle and you're like oh of
course that piece has to go there right
but when you're looking at like i did a
puzzle um in the last school holidays um
when we were much sooner into lockdown
um where there was like this one section
and i swear the whole section was just
black right and you're like there's like
15 pieces and they're all black and
you're like i don't know like you can't
like the number of permutations there
are for how they all fit together you
just have to use the shapes of the
pieces rather than their color to try
and work out how they fit and to begin a
question like this feels a little bit
like that right i saw some people
thinking about how to use internal ratio
division formulas because that's kind of
sort of what you've got here um if you
think back to what we were doing here
with m's and n's that might be familiar
because that's often literally the
letters that are used um and another few
people who i saw used a method to do
with similar triangles which i will show
you but i'll have you think about why
that method while it works in fact it is
the first method i came up with just
when i was having a go at this
why that method whilst valid is
marvelously inelegant and inefficient
i'll show you why once we get there okay
so
what more sophisticated knowledge do we
have to access to to solve this and i
want you to recognize the fact that
because t
is the intersection of p r and o s p r
and o s and then t is the intersection
point right i wonder if that clues you
into a piece of knowledge from um
vectors that we've learnt in extension
one or two that sort of makes mints made
of this question if you use it
appropriately and that is when you're
trying to find a point of intersection
if you have the equations of those two
lines all you have to do is solve
simultaneously which we are exceedingly
good at and you're off and to the races
so really the tricky part is can i work
out what the appropriate equations are
and then solving them is actually the
easy part okay
so we've got pr and os i'm going to do
them in reverse order and you'll see why
in a second so let's think about line os
for a moment
what is its equation well if you think
about vector equations i'm going to call
this um normally we use like r as our
you know whatever equals but r's been
taken in this question so i'm going to
call it l for line we have two every
vector equation of a line is made up of
two pieces right there's the position
vector it's like what's the vector that
gets you onto that line and then there's
the direction vector which says like
once you're on the line like which way
are you facing okay now not a trick
question but it is a little bit weird in
this case what would be the position
vector or one of the appropriate or the
easiest position vector to use for line
os
think about it carefully here's os right
here okay um
i wonder if you guys can post in the
chat what the appropriate uh position
vector is what's the easiest vector to
add to get onto line os can anyone tell
me
yeah bam well done anger's uh got it in
one when you think you start from the
origin right but line os it goes through
the origin so no position vector or no
further position vector is required to
get onto this line so i'm just going to
leave like a conspicuous absence here
for the position vector and then i add
on the direction vector right so
there'll be some parameter we usually
use lambda and then you say well from
now we're on the line os what direction
do you need to look in well to to get
along from o to s
the easiest way is to say well you go
along o r and then you go along r s the
reason being you know what both of these
vectors are
part of the pun o r is little r and you
can tell me what rs is equal to right
can you again post it in the chat what
would it be
this vector given the information that
you've been told in the question even on
the diagram what is rs going to be equal
to how can you state it in terms of the
vectors you've been told
any takers
who can see it
well our anger is just too too quick
we're going to have to um we're going to
have to let other people have a chance
anger and thank you for contributing so
helpfully it's um half because you've
got this midpoint here s is the midpoint
of r q and it's uh
parallel to p so the directions are the
same but the magnitude is halved right
so therefore my direction vector for
line os is going to be there's my lambda
for the parameter and it's going to be r
plus half p
bam that's it that is line os
now all i need to do is work out what
line pr is and then i can solve these
simultaneously so pr takes a little more
thinking but not much right again i'm
going to call this l
and i think now again i need a position
vector right i've got to get onto the
line pr first here we go
there are two obvious ways to do it you
can either use p to get onto the line or
you can use r to get onto the line it
really doesn't matter as we've seen
before there's an infinite number of
valid
vector equations for a single line
because your position vector can take
you anywhere on to the line that you
like i'm just going to go with p just
because that's the alphabetical easiest
one to get to
be careful here there's another
parameter that gets used but it may not
be the same parameter that we got before
the lambda parameter so um you know you
might call it something else like say mu
choose whatever greek letter suits your
fancy and now i need a direction vector
right so i've successfully gone up onto
the line pr so here i am at p
after doing this
little p vector and now i need to go
along this line here either either
direction really uh it makes sense to go
from p
to r so i hope you can see that's
negative p plus r or more easily written
r take away p okay so there's the
direction vector moving from p to r um
by way of the origin okay
and once you've done this
you just need to solve simultaneously so
it's still a three mark
proof so i will say sol simultaneously
and i'm just going to take the
right-hand sides of both of these
equations and land them together right
so what have i got here let's be i'm
going to be a bit cheap sorry just for
the sake of time and hopefully you guys
be able to um
right and catch up with me there's my
left and my right hand side
and what i'm trying to solve here for is
that there's a particular
parameter either lambda or mu that will
get me to this point t right does that
make sense
you know i can
travel along os using by varying the
parameter lambda but there's a
particular lambda that will get me to
this spot here or
it's just as valid to say um either some
particular parameter mu which as i
travel along pr will get me to this
particular spot t right so that's what
i'm trying to find a value of lambda or
a value for mu either of them will do
right so the way i'm going to do that is
i'm going to just tidy this up a little
bit by expanding both sides right
usually expanding makes things worse but
why is expanding here going to make
things easier i actually might put this
in alphabetical order you'll see why in
a second i'm going to get a half lambda
p here on the left hand side and then on
the right hand side have a look here
right if i am collecting like terms here
how many of the little p vectors do i
have i have one here and i have minus mu
of them here right so therefore i can
factorize that out one minus mu
lots of the p vector and then i've got
mu lots of the r vector okay
why did i arrange it in this way well
it's because it enables me to compare
these coefficients here can you see that
it's why i put it in alphabetical order
p first and then r there's a lambda here
and a mu there so comparing my
coefficients or equating coded
coefficients
because
i know that these two
have to be these two sets of things the
p and the r's have to be equal to each
other let's do the blue ones first
because they're pretty easy right lambda
is going to equal mu and i should say
i get that from
the r vectors
let's call that equation one and then
from the
p
vectors what do i get on the left hand
side i've got half lambda on the right
hand side i've got one take away mu and
now i can use
you know this result that i just
substituted in here i can get rid of the
muse
and get half lambda here and one minus
lambda from
equation one above and from here it's
kind of i'm almost home right i'll add a
lambda to both sides that gives me one
and a half or three on two lambdas on
the left hand side and then i can just
multiply through by two-thirds to get
the particular
parameter that i'm after right
so
what have i just done remember what i
was trying to do right
line os line pr they both go through t
but there's a particular lambda and a
particular mu that will get me exactly
onto t and i've just found it it's
lambda equals two thirds and by the way
lambda is easier to use because if you
have a look um this equation for os is
simpler than the equation for pr though
i could have easily i mean i can take mu
equals two-thirds because apparently
nu and lambda are the same anyway that's
what i just worked out but let's put it
into let's substitute it into line os
substitute into os
and this should hopefully give me the
result i was going for right so it's
going to be l equals
here comes the particular lambda that i
found two thirds and i'm multiplying by
r plus half p
from memory
and then you can see if you just
cast one eye towards the result you're
trying to prove that is the two thirds r
plus one third p that they were after so
i'm just gonna conclude that with as
required okay